encuentra la ecuación de la recta
perpendicular a diente igual a menos dos
quintos de x 3 que pase por el punto 28
bien la primera parte de información que
nos dan es que queremos una recta
perpendicular una recta perpendicular a
esta que nos dan y que significa eso
bueno pues una recta que sea
perpendicular a esta recta debe de tener
una pendiente que sea inversa negativa
de menos dos quintos
así que si empezamos con una pendiente
de menos dos quintos y me fijo en estos
dos quintos y me tomo su inverso
eso va a ser bueno pues cinco medios así
que déjame ponerlo cinco medios y bueno
le cambiamos el signo éste era negativo
así que nuestra pendiente será positiva
nuestra pendiente será positiva
esta es la inversa negativa de menos dos
quintos le cambias el signo
se vuelve positivo y después volteas
este 2 y este 5 y quedan 5 medios cinco
medios positivos esta va a ser nuestra
pendiente y ya con esto podemos usar la
fórmula punto pendiente porque nos dicen
que pasa por este punto por el punto 2,8
así que hacemos punto pendiente
- y bueno me voy a tomar este 8 es decir
el valor de y en el punto que sabemos
que está en esta recta 10 menos 8 va a
ser igual a la pendiente a nuestra
pendiente que es 5 medios 5 medios esto
que a su vez multiplica a x menos 22 el
valor que tiene que tomar x cuando lleva
les corts y esta es nuestra ecuación de
la recta en la forma punto pendiente y
si la queremos en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen bueno entonces
hagamos un poco de álgebra un poco de
manipulación algebraica así que lo
primero que vamos a hacer es distribuir
estos cinco medios y me va a quedar
cinco medios por x es cinco medios de x
cinco medios x y después cinco medios
por menos dos bueno primero voy a
colocar aquí este signo y cinco medios
por 2
5 de lujo y después vamos a sumar 8 de
ambos lados y entonces me va a quedar
que james es igual a 5 medios de x y
después tengo más 8 menos 5 bueno 8
menos 5 es lo mismo que 3 así que aquí
me va a quedar 3 positivos y lo hemos
logrado así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo